Transpose of a matrix is this original matrix with it's rows and columns flipped
along the diagonal. There are two diagonals but the one I mean is from the upper
left to the lower right. It's where we put the scale factors for example. Here
I'm showing the original matrix A,B,C,D and so on with column order. What we do
to transpose is we flip along the diagonal and they're now in this order. The
mathematical notation for this is M superscript T, where T means transpose. The
other operation that is commonly done to a matrix is computing its inverse. The
inverse is shown like this a negative 1 in the superscript. If you multiply a
matrix by its inverse, you get the identity matrix. The inverse of a matrix
essentially undoes the work of that matrix. For example, if your matrix moves an
object five units up, the inverse moves it five units down. The inverse of a
rotation matrix is one that rotates on the same axis but back the other
direction. The inverse of a scale matrix scales the object back down. Let's look
at the inverses of some common transform matrices. For translation, we start
with our translation values over here. The inverse is the negation of all those
translation values. Which makes sense. You move to one direction, and then you
come back the other direction. For any rotation matrix, it turns out that the
inverse is the transpose. So, for this one, for example. Its rotation around the
z axis and you simply transpose these two elements and you know have the inverse
of the z rotation. For a scale matrix, we divide one by the original scale
factors. Or to say it more mathematically. We take the multiplicative inverse of
each scale factor. Things get more complex when we combine rotation, translation
and scale matrices. The inverse of a matrix representing a complex series of
transforms is usually not obvious. I won't spend the time explaining how to
compute an inverse that's a whole lesson of linear algebra. The good news is
that every graphics library in the know universe. Has a matrix inversion routine
of some sort. Three.js is no exception. Matrix4 class has a getInverse function.